[Applause]
this I want to show you the common
mistake
okay um and I want to point out that
when you go when you're trying to learn
something it's better to go slow it's
just better to go slow uh the
uncultivated Mind becomes easily
fettered and it gets fettered by a
quicker Tempo more than it does by a
slower Tempo so you have to go slow now
the downside of that is that same feder
mind is also it's a spiritual immaturity
Ferness is a spiritual immaturity so the
same spiritual
immaturity will uh
aize the self and end up doing things as
if they're superhuman and so they start
to do things unrealistic things that
would not work at faster harder more
intense tempos again so the problem is
I have a FedEd mind okay use a slower
Tempo however the slower Tempo allows
for huge deviation from what is
practical what is viable okay and so a
uh problem that comes up from the slower
Tempo is the following one so let's put
the camera over here on this
side
okay and it is a premature
Ely
um ending the yin phases of the sword
okay which you can do when there's no
real pressure okay um and so what I mean
by that is you got to go really slow so
I can talk and do this okay as he's
doing a legit AOS that's attacking and
finding my Center do you
see I have to take that pressure
off and his pressure is going all the
way it's going down Okay so this sword
has to uh it cannot pick up here it
cannot pick up here if he's loose loose
like looser do looser bead Lane loose
don't you're Dro I don't even want its
weight you're holding I want you to hold
it up so there's no y on it you see that
okay very common someone short changes
the atos because they have they feel in
their head they need to hurry up and do
the makush block okay so now when it's
like this then I could do this do you
see that and so you get this kind of
Sword movement on the side of your
body with the Suka never coming to the
top of the head okay nor nor the the tip
dropping so again a lot you I in
particular you'll have a lot of people
that sword never never drops on the back
yeah cuz you have a lot of idealized
okay weapons wind up they wind
up all the time okay so I have to this
sword has to move all the way so that I
completely neutralize his y energy okay
so as we go around and he goes I can't
pick it up up there it's too heavy so I
had to come all the way around to get
completely off and that's what's going
to have that tip back there if I H if I
shoot for this I'm telling you you
picked it up where there's young
movement you got to get it all the way
to the back of your body and you can see
the sword tip camera can you over here
where I'm pointing go go go Virginia go
over there and you see the tip dropped
okay that's to free me and it's going to
happen again over here so as he goes on
okay and as he does the
atos I'm going to do it this time this
way all right and as he skis you're
going to go slow again for me as he
starts to come up I am now parrying this
weapon so stay there again if I do again
a little short thing that has that tip
come up I am actually enrange for no you
don't even have to move just change the
angle of the ski so that he hits okay I
have to let him get deep into the
initial ski and in order for me to do
that the Perry has to go all the way
around as he goes I'm here to free the Y
the Yang energy here that tip has to
drop all the way as he goes
boom here the tip has to drop all the
way to free that y energy and as he
comes in the tip has to stay drop to
keep it from tracking me and as I move
that tip's going to be down again in the
back
okay so if I come around he could do
whatever cuz that's a cheap ass shot but
if he feels my pressure I won't do it
fast but I'll put pressure on it you see
what it does to his SW do you feel that
okay and maybe you have to come again
over
here so this movement isn't that where
he can do whatever there's an attack
down boom he has to get that out so his
tip is going to be pointing down and
then he cuts and then the same thing
going to happen here his tip has to
point down so he's Point your tip down
dude break your weapon go back
tip down tip
down again boom tip down boom you don't
have to point it in the
ground over your
head
go you
see you see
again I don't have to do that boom this
no boom
that
okay free good boom free it you do drop
cuz you there is some pressure do you
feel it you see you got to drop and then
you point it down drop point it down
that's it okay now Short change this
make a quick come off of it early there
it is and you're going to hit him he
can't can't take his tip from the down
position until I've pass his body so go
back here it is he's going to follow
that weapon all the way through and
that's going to put the tip go back to
where it
is follow it all the way through stop at
the end and you can see the tip's going
to be down okay we try it again you look
lost do you
understand
tip
down boom tip
down tip down till he clears it there
you go okay and that's going to
stop this stuff where you're
here boom and you come around and you do
again a little movement okay because
you're not clear you have to do what you
have to do to neutralize WR energy and
to not create another un open okay so
the movement of the sword is much Fuller
on the last one so you
cut good and I go here you can see he
does not have to drop the tip on this
one so as I go in he doesn't have to
drop the tip you see and there's your
Aikido wet dream your sword did not drop
in the back you get it and now you can
cream all over it okay
all right here we go